- Look at them flub-a-duff
flubbin' the dubbin'
'n' havin' a foof-a-rah
(violin chamber music)
- [Voiceover] Flub the dub.
- Flub the dub. Oh.
- That just sounds dirty.
- That for sure means jerking off.
- I'm flubbin' the dub?
- No, isn't that?
It sounds like, it'd be
like to make a mistake.
You'd be like, "Oh,
man, I flubbed the dub."
Or buffa the, what is it?
- I think, it just means
like, you just don't work.
You're not.
He's just flubbing the dub.
- No. It's jerking off.
- I think it's jerking off too.
- [Voiceover] To avoid
one's work or duties.
- Okay. So, you're an asshole
essentially.
(man drowned out by woman)
- Are you gonna get down to your work?
Or are you gonna just keep
flubbing the dub all day?
- [Voiceover] Foofooraw.
- [Together] Foofooraw.
- You are looking foofooraw today.
- That's like a rager.
- We went over to David's.
It was quite the foofooraw.
- [Voiceover] A loud disturbance.
- What are these kids
and their foofooraws.
- So it's kinda like a brouhaha.
- Yeah, it's a brouhaha, like a ruckus.
- [Voiceover] Bun-struggle.
- This sounds like a hair problem.
- That was when like you
would go to a restaurant
and you wouldn't get enough buns pre-meal.
- I'm out of bread
and you're like, "Oop.
"It's the bun-struggle, Honey."
- Yeah.
- Livin' that bun-struggle life.
- [Voiceover] A formal tea.
- A formal tea?
- So the opposite of a struggle.
Like a nice sit-down.
- Care for some bun-struggle?
I'm like, "(bleeped out), no way."
- Do you want a bun-struggle?
- [Voiceover] Buttinsky.
- [Together] Buttinsky?
- That's like the guy you
hate on your football team.
- Yeah, like he's always in trouble.
- Yeah.
- Always.
- I bet buttinsky's something cool.
- Okay.
- [Woman] Um.
(man laughs)
- [Voiceover] A person who
rudely intrudes himself.
- Always you. (laughs)
- Why yes, a buttinsky.
- Yeah.
- The kid you hated in elementary school.
- In my heyday, that buttinsky
used to flub the dub.
- I am gonna go back and
use all these words, though.
- Slang today is way shorter.
- We get, like, pissed,
if we have to type L-O-L.
That's three letters.
- Years from now, when
we're dead, they'll be like,
"Why the hell did you
say, 'Awesomesauce'?"
- You say "rad" a lot. That's rad.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah.
- Oh.
- What did Netflix and chill mean?
- Who creates all these words,
and then makes them popular?
- Flubbin' the dub.
I mean, that's,
we know what that means.
We could bring that back.
(violin chamber music)